The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: If you
look at syllabus,
I have my office hour
Monday 5:00 to 6:00.
And I would like to--
I know many of you, but also,
many of you I do not know.
If we have not met
before, I would
like to ask you to
come to my office hour,
and let's chat a little bit
and see what your interest.
That way, I can
better prepare myself.
I also read that through your
feedback in the first class.
As I expected, the
interest varies broadly.
And also, the background
varies broadly.
That's always the nature
I encounter in the past,
and we don't have a
good solution for that.
So I ask, if you have learned
this stuff, be patient.
If you haven't, we'll get there.
And many of you, also, are
very much interested in liquid.
So I want to tell you that
liquid is very difficult.
And when I wrote the book, I put
everything on a parallel paths.
I can deal with solid--
crystal solid,
crystalline solid--
and gas-- photons, electrons.
But when it came to liquid, it
became a lot more complicated.
So if you look at
the book, there
was a specific
chapter on liquid.
And then, you have
to be more patient
and wait until almost
the end of this class.
OK, with that, remember,
I would like to see you.
If we haven't talked before,
come to my office hour.
And let's know
each other better.
If you think about what we
talked in the last lecture,
last time we reviewed the
classical laws for heat,
for momentum--
heat conduction, heat
convection, thermal radiation.
In terms of momentum, for
example, the [INAUDIBLE] shear
stress [INAUDIBLE].
And we all saw Ohm's law,
mass diffusion, Fick's law.
So those are the
constitute relations
for the transport processes.
So the classical laws.
And also, we went into
more microscopic picture
behind these classical laws.
And we say, at the end,
in terms of carriers
for energy, momentum,
charge, we only
have essentially four types--
major types-- molecules,
electrons, photons,
and lattice vibration.
I brought up the name phonons.
So we went to some
microscopic description
for those transport processes.
And what I simplify this
problem is a gas picture.
I have molecular gas in a box.
I have electron gas in a
box and the photon gas box.
So that's why we can do a
parallel treatment for all
those energy carriers.
And what I'm going to
do in today's lecture
is trying to give a first
crack on the questions
that we're going to answer
through the whole semester.
And those questions-- what are
the questions I want to ask?
I want to ask, now, if I look
at those microscopic picture,
I want to take, first,
one individual carrier
and ask, what's its energy?
I can also ask, what's
the momentum, charge?
But let me just pick
the energy first.
And then I'm going to
look at a cluster, a box
of those carriers, molecules.
At certain temperature, I ask,
how many of those carriers
have certain energy and
how fast they travel?
So first question is, how much?
OK, here can see
how much energy,
but there's one carrier.
And then I'm going
to ask, how many
of them, and how
fast they travel,
and how far they travel,
and how they interact.
OK.
And with that, we can start--
I give you a simple derivation
of the diffusion laws.
Last time, we showed
Ohm's law, for example.
This time, I will show you the
Fourier heat conduction law.
And with that, you can go
back and do other laws--
the Fick's law and
Newton's shear stress law.
These can all be similarly done.
So let's look at
per energy of per
carrier, so we
can say, how much?
Look at the one carrier.
So I have a box
of gas molecules.
Let's say, I have hydrogen. And
this is a diatomic molecule,
so we have two hydrogen atoms.
And one hydrogen and
another hydrogen atom--
they are bound together.
And then when I look at the
energy of this molecule,
I look at the possible modes,
possible ways of storing energy
by the molecule.
What other forms of energy--
AUDIENCE: Kinetic and potential.
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Kinetic
and potential energy.
PROFESSOR: OK, so we
have kinetic energy.
That's a translation.
So this hydrogen molecule
is moving around, right?
And in that case, I
look at the mass center.
I can say, OK, I don't
care about these two
individual atoms.
They are just a cluster, and
they move at certain velocity.
And the kinetic energy, E,
equals 1/2 mv squared, right?
So last time I made a statement
if you understand energy,
and momentum, and entropy.
And now we're looking-- go
into the molecular picture
and look at those energy.
So this is a translation--
kinetic energy.
What other energies?
AUDIENCE: Rotational
and vibrational.
PROFESSOR: Rotation, vibration.
And let's look at the vibration.
So these two molecules
are bound by spring.
We, in fact, talked about
the inter-atomic force
in the last lecture.
The minimum point
is the equilibrium.
So we can approximate
as a spring.
And this is a relative vibration
within these two atoms.
That's another way
to store the energy.
So the vibration-- and in fact,
that you can simplify this
because this now is
the two atom motion.
But if you simplify it relative
to the center of the mass,
you can essentially do an
effective mass spring problem.
So this is a classical
mass spring problem.
And for this classical spring
mass, what's the energy?
Energy-- let's say you
have the displacement is x.
AUDIENCE: 1/2kx squared.
PROFESSOR: OK.
1/2kx squared.
That's the potential.
There's another part.
One translation,
also, mv squared.
This is a way--
now the center of mass moving,
it's a relative vibration,
so the mass is
relative to the center.
AUDIENCE: In terms of the
potential energy, or--
PROFESSOR: This is
the potential energy--
kx squared.
AUDIENCE: OK, then
those potential energy
would start to [INAUDIBLE]
gravitational potential energy?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I'm not considering gravity.
You can add a gravitation.
Yeah, that's possible.
OK, so we have vibration, and
you also mentioned rotation.
So we have, also, rotation.
And rotation is, now, I
can take a simple picture.
I fix this spring,
and now I have
a rod with two balls attached
to it, and they will rotate.
And the energy-- rotational
energy is 1/2 i omega squared.
i is the moment of inertia, and
omega is the angular momentum--
the angular velocity.
So we have translation,
vibration, rotation.
Anything else?
Don't forget a charge.
So if I look at
individual hydrogen atom
and it has nuclei, and it
has electrons moving around.
So we also have electronic.
And the electronic energy, I can
write a-- either use E symbol
or potential--
the interacting of two charge.
Let's say here is q1.
Here is q2.
Then the cooling potential--
the cooling interaction,
two charges.
Anyone remember that?
q1 and q2, 4 pi epsilon r.
Epsilon is dielectric constant.
r is the separation
between the two.
OK, so those are
the form of energy
this molecule stores within.
So when we think about
internal energy of a gas,
they are stored in those
forms-- translation, vibration,
rotation, electronic.
And so that's the
case of a molecule.
And if we go to solid, which
is a lot more complex--
we'll talk more later.
But the last time, we
gave a simple picture
of connected the atom by
spring, so it has a vibration.
And also, each atom has
electrons and nuclei,
so it has the electronic.
And in fact, for solid, it
doesn't have this rotation.
The atoms don't rotate.
It's fixed there.
So in that sense, that's better.
When I deal with
the liquid, I have
more trouble because of all
those other possibilities.
So let's leave this to later.
And what I want to say is, those
are all the classical form,
classical expressions.
And the what we're
going to move on next
is to give the quantized form.
In quantum mechanics,
what are the energy
of the translation, vibration,
rotation, and electronic?
And there, we'll say the
quantization of energy levels.
And that's very important.
Now, this is a
individual energy--
how much?
What do we look next
is, how many of them?
And I have a box
of molecules, here.
And of course, I can say,
well, per unit volume,
this is the number of
molecules per unit volume.
That's the number of
But each molecule could
have one half of mv squared.
Now, v, in my current
picture, is not defined--
velocity.
It could be anywhere
from negative infinite
velocity to vector,
negative infinite
to positive and infinite.
So the question
is, if I give you
a box of gas at certain
temperature, T--
now I'm bringing
the thermal part--
how much energy-- what's the
probability of the molecule
has certain value of energy, E?
Because the number of
molecules is very large,
I have to bring in the
statistical picture.
So at temperature T,
temperature T is--
let's look at the
translation only.
So I can simplify my picture
even more simplified.
I don't consider hydrogen atom.
I consider helium atom.
Monatomic gas--
translation energy only.
Of course, there's
electronic part.
So at temperature
T, how much is--
say, what's the
probability of a molecule
has, actually, certain
value of energy?
What's the answer?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this is going into the
statistical thermal physics--
statistical physics.
And the distribution is given
by the famous Boltzmann factor.
I try to use all capitals, now.
So Boltzmann factor
tells you the probability
of finding a
molecule or atom has
certain energy, E,
at temperature, T,
is a normalization.
This is a probability.
So it has a normalization
constant minus E over kBT.
And this kB is the
Boltzmann constant
we mentioned last time. kB
is a 1.38 10 to the minus 23
joule per Kelvin.
So that's the Boltzmann factor.
And some of you taken
statistical physics,
and that's easy.
If you haven't taken it,
you learned [INAUDIBLE] law.
Any time people look at that
the temperature dependent,
they always like to pull
that exponential factor.
That's because the
Boltzmann is behind it.
And then we'll come
back to this later on.
So I'm going to build on
this exponential factor
to determine, what's the
average energy per molecule--
translation energy per
molecule, and how to do it?
First, I need to find this
normalization factor, A,
and then I determine
this probability.
So let's examine the
translational energy--
mv squared.
So v really is a vector.
So vx, vy, vz.
So I'll write, vx squared plus
vy squared plus vz squared.
And now, I take advantage
of the definition
for this f probability is
I find the molecule having
velocity from minus
infinite to plus infinite.
Mass will normalize to what?
That's all the
range you can have.
So from the normalization--
from minus infinite to plus
infinite-- for vx, vy, vz--
first, I'll do it in
Cartesian coordinate,
then I'll transfer to
spherical coordinate.
So let's look at,
first, Cartesian
coordinate from minus
infinite to plus infinite dvx,
minus infinite to
plus infinite dvy.
And one warning is
that you will often
encounter many of
these integral forms
because when we look
at the probability,
we have to integrate from
all the possible states.
So vx, vy, vz.
And f-- so I put the
Boltzmann factor.
So this integrant is--
I'm going to be lazy.
I'm not writing that exponential
E, T. So you put it in there.
This should equal to 1.
You look at it.
If you plug in your
E in vx squared,
vy squared, vz squared,
and you can factor it out
and you can do your integration
for dvx individually, dvy
individually, dvz individually.
And with that, you only have
a constant A you do not know,
and you determine
that constant A.
So I'm now going
through the integral.
And you can either check
the integration table,
or there is a nice
mathematical trick.
If you like to play, you can
find that integration value.
So here, what I have
is 2 pi kBT 3/2.
3/2 is because each of
this contributes 1/2.
OK So now, I have--
if I plug in this A into the f,
I get f in terms of vx, vy, vz.
The distribution
at temperature T
is m, 2 pi kBT, 3/2 exponential.
I want to write the whole thing.
So this is vx squared plus vy
squared plus vz squared divide
by 2 kBT.
And this is the
Maxwell distribution--
Maxwell velocity distribution.
So it looks pretty tedious.
But essentially, it's 1/2--
it's an energy expression--
1/2 mv squared.
Maxwell-- what have you
heard about Maxwell?
What other things have
you heard about Maxwell?
Maxwell equations-- you probably
heard that rather than this.
Let's say, in fact, you look
at all those very famous people
in the 1800s, 1900.
They have done many things.
Newton-- not just the
Newton mechanics law.
Newton optics, also.
You can do all that.
OK, here is velocity.
Using vx, vy, vz, I could make
my life much easier if I use--
very often when I
do this integration,
I change the coordinates.
Rather than dvx, dvy, dvz,
I do a spherical coordinate
because it's symmetric.
so if I change my
coordinate from a dvx, dvy,
dvz into a spherical
coordinate, due to symmetry,
it's 4 pi v squared dv.
V, now, is they r--
the radius.
And so the range of v is
from 0 to positive infinite.
It's not from negative
infinite to infinite, right?
When you do-- if you think
about from dx, dy, dz into r
coordinate.
OK, so because of that
my normalization-- when
I do normalization, if I
use spherical coordinate,
it's 0 to infinite.
And the fv, now I do
not use the vx, vy, vz.
I use the fv and dv equals 1.
That's another way to do it.
And in this case, your
fv equals 4 pi v squared,
m 2 pi kBT, 3/2 exponential
minus mv squared over 2kBT.
It's simple rewriting the
Cartesian into a spherical.
But the point I want to make is
if you use v, you do not do--
because the 4 pi v squared
is already included here.
So you can't substitute
this back into here
and just do your
vx, vy, vz, again.
That's deconsistent
which coordinate system
you will be using.
OK, so what does this
tell me, this math?
I'm jumping into
a little bit math.
Because f is a probability,
so now with that probability,
I can calculate the average.
I can calculate what's the
average energy per molecule,
what's the average--
any other numbers that
you will be interested.
So if I calculate the
average, E, per molecule--
the translation-- so my
average will be-- now,
depend on which
system you choose.
You can do Cartesian, or
you can do the spherical.
Now, I'm going to write
simply as a spherical, so 0
to infinite.
And the energy is
1/2 mv squared.
That's the average quantity--
the quantity I want to find.
What's the average it
given my f distribution?
So I times fv.
I integrate the over v.
Now you can do your math
to find out the integral.
OK, that's why I'm
warning you, you
don't want to--
if you use v, you
want to be consistently all
v. You don't do vx, vy, vz.
If you do vx, vy, vz,
you start from here.
You do your Cartesian
at the beginning.
That f is different
from what I write here.
It's the same thing, but
just to be consistency.
So again, I say, you
can do that homework.
And what you have
here is 1/3 kBT.
All that math gives you a very
beautiful, very simple result.
So kBT is a quantity
you will see often
if you go to microscopic work.
That's the thermal energy--
average thermal energy,
translation energy
of the molecule.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So do not divide by
the integral from 0 to 3 of 1/2
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: If you divide
by this, that's 1.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: So I already--
that's why my
normalization factor--
we're doing the
normalization factor.
OK, so with this,
I can go to say,
what's the average velocity?
I say, how much here is--
how much the average energy
per particle?
Let's say, based on this,
because of this translation,
1/2 mv squared, so what's the
average speed of the molecule?
So we can go to calculate it.
So I have average 1/2mv
squared equals 2/3 kBT.
And v squared--
I take a square root of that so
I can tell the magnitude is--
here I have 3kBT over m.
OK, what's the
order of magnitude?
Let's put in numbers.
I always like to put in numbers.
I take a helium gas.
And helium, I can
count how many--
what's the mass?
Helium has two neutrons, two
protons, two electron masses--
two electron masses
are two thousandths--
1 over 2000 of the
mass of protons.
I forget about
the electron mass.
So it's 4 times proton mass.
Proton mass-- 1/67 10
to the minus 31 kilo.
I can only remember SI unit.
Not 31-- I'm sorry.
That's 31 is the election--
27.
OK, so if I plug in this
mass, kBT is the 1.38 10
to the minus 23.
Temperature is 300 Kelvin.
So what I'll get is
average velocity--
speed, this one is 1.36 10 to
the third meter per second.
It's about 1,000
meters per second.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you know what the
variance is for the velocity?
PROFESSOR: You could
go to calculate.
You can calculate the--
it's also kBT.
It's v minus v squared.
Do that.
You'll get also kBT.
That's the variance.
OK, so this is helium.
Now, if you put air--
air average mass 27.
So you put in 27, you'll get
about 500 meter per second.
Those molecules are
moving pretty fast.
And the last lecture, we
discussed the momentum,
the pressure.
We're feeling 1
atmospheric pressure,
and that's the momentum from
these fast-moving molecules.
So one more comment--
and this 3/2 kBT, there is
a very fundamental theory
behind this.
And that is if the
distribution of base--
the Boltzmann distribution--
and at high temperature--
so by doing that
high temperature,
I can do the integration.
Later on, when we
introduce quantum,
you can't do the
integration anymore.
So at high temperature,
the energy very close,
so I can do integration.
And if the energy form--
for each energy form,
if it's quadratic--
so what do I mean?
So if you look at
the kinetic energy,
this is 1/2 mv x squared, right?
So each quadratic form, if you
go to do the average energy,
you find that average
energy is 1/2 kT.
So 1/2 kT, 1/2
kT, that's 3/2 kT.
And that's called the
equipartition theorem.
Again, that's an example of
the translational energy.
And if you go to
vibration, you see here,
it's a quadratic term--
1/2 kx squared.
The velocity-- 1/2 mv squared.
So at very high
temperature, this is 1/2 kT,
averagely speaking,
this is 1/2 kT.
And the rotation--
1/2 omega squared.
Against, it's quadratic.
At high temperature,
that's 1/2 kT.
And in fact, the rotation
at high temperature
is only 80 Kelvin
or so for molecules.
The vibration is go to
a few thousand degree.
So that's why you learn
the ideal gas law before.
cv for different monotonic
ideal gas, diatomic ideal gas--
they have different cv values.
That's because diatomic gas,
you have the rotational modes
coming in.
And monotonic, only
the translation.
That's the
equipartition theorem.
Well, we'll go to discuss
that more later on.
But here, with that, we've
got to fill in how fast
and how much energy they have.
Next, what do we want to
answer is how far they travel.
OK, so we have--
how far they travel.
By how far, I mean think about
the air molecules in this room.
We have huge number.
Always, I give
numbers 10 to 23rd--
one more.
Huge number of
molecules, and they
will collide with each other.
So normally they carry their
energy, and then the next time,
they collide with
another molecule.
So I want to give a very
quick estimation, what's
the distance between
those collision?
How far they travel?
And so to do that,
let's say, in this case,
I have to think about the
molecule along a point, right?
final size of the molecule.
Its final size-- if you think
what determines the size,
it could be the electric
field potential.
You have a nuclei,
and then there's
a electric field spill out.
And then when the two molecules
collide with each other,
that's when the fields
start to interact.
And so I give, let's say, a
diameter of a molecule as D.
This diameter could be,
typically, a few angstroms--
1 angstrom, 2 angstroms.
OK.
And now, if I think about
this molecule final size,
it's moving.
And the collision happens
when there is another molecule
within distance of D, right?
So this is 2D.
And the way I can think about it
and do a very quick estimation
is, let's say I have a molecule,
and over a trajectory--
2-- of diameter 2D--
it travel a certain distance.
So this tube is diameter 2D.
And travel a certain
distance-- let's say,
here, this distance is L.
And then, what's the volume?
So that tube is the
area times distance.
So the volume is
4 pi 2D squared--
this is the area--
times the length
gives me the volume
that this molecule,
this tube sweeps.
Now, how I decide the average
distance between 1 collision,
that is when the number
density per unit volume--
this is the number of
molecules per unit volume--
times the volume--
when that equals 1.
That's one collision.
Do you agree?
So when the average number
of, say, the per unit volume--
what's the number of molecule--
times over this tube of 2D,
the length, L,
when this equals 1,
that's one collision
this molecule
will have with other molecules.
And under this one
condition that L is really
what I call the mean free
path, the average distance
between collision,
equals, here, you
can say is pi D squared times n.
This is the mean free
path that the molecule
travels between collision.
And if you do a
better job, this one
is assuming the other
molecules do not move--
just a stationary
distribute there.
And if you do more
detail, it turns out
this expression is
still pretty good.
So the mean free path--
mean free path is--
more accurate that is
put the square root of 2
here is pi D squared times n.
Now with that, we
can go to guess
estimate the mean free
path of the air molecules--
a typical gas.
So if it's a gas--
ideal gas.
If it's ideal gas and
we know pressure--
we derived last time,
in fact-- is nkBT,
n is the number of particles
per unit volume, nothing more--
fraction.
So this is number of
particles per unit volume.
So I replaced this n.
And in this case, what I
get the mean free path is
kBT, square root of 2,
pi D squared pressure.
OK, so let's put it
in number and m what's
the mean free path in
a typical condition?
Gamma is-- kBT is kB is 1.38 10
to the minus 23 joules Kelvin
times 300 Kelvin.
And square root of 2 pi D.
D let me take 2.5 angstrom--
this is by no means
meant to be accurate--
meter squared.
Pressure-- 1 atmosphere, so 110
to the fifth Newton per meter
squared.
And you go to put in all the
number, so this is minus 23rd.
This is minus 20.
And here-- so that means
the 20-- minus 20--
minus 3.
And here is 10 the fifth.
So minus 8.
And this 300-- you go
to check your numbers.
I'll give you a value I have.
This one I get 0.14.
So 0.14 micron-- so 10 to
the minus 600 nanometer.
That's about the
average distance
the air molecules
travel in this room.
And if you recall, before
I said a disk drive--
and the disk in my [INAUDIBLE]
is a few nanometer, now,
the separation.
And they're still
using fluid mechanics
to design their slider
so that they do not
collide with the disk.
And you come to a regime
where the air molecules do not
collide with each other,
they'll collide with boundary
more often.
So this is the average
mean free pass.
Now, you can say in
the case of ideal gas,
the pressure is in
the denominator.
How many of you do
vacuum-related, vacuum
experience?
So vacuum-- typical vacuum--
let's say, 10 to minus 6 torr.
You can use a typical diffusion
pump to easily derive 10
to minus 6 torr.
So what's the molecule
mean free pass
when it's 10 to minus 6 torr?
I put in there 10 to minus
torr is 10 to the minus 6--
remember, here is
10 to the fifth.
But the one torr is 760--
1 atmosphere is 760 torr.
So this is the pressure
you put in there,
and you get 100 meter.
So in vacuum pump--
vacuum system-- the molecule
do not collide with each other.
You use a evaporator.
You heat it up.
You heat the atom.
The atom go out.
It goes straight to your target.
So it's completely a
ballistic trajectory.
You don't do the heat induction
diffusion theory anymore.
You have to trace
the trajectory.
OK, so this is how far--
we have some idea.
And next, let's
briefly discuss how
they interact with each other.
How do they interact?
And I mentioned when the
two molecules collided
with each other it's
really the electric field
extend certain space and
when the two molecules get
close, the electric field
collide, say, repel each other.
So they go different trajectory.
So you have simple--
you can think about that
two billiard ball collision.
And if you want to do
the trajectory, what
do you do is during
the coalition,
you have energy conservation.
You have momentum conservation.
So in that case,
this is really--
the microscopic world-- the
basic conservation laws,
the conservation
principle apply.
So you have energy and
momentum conservation.
And if the collision is
among the air molecules,
typically, it's
limited how fast--
how far the molecule travel.
So it's an internal--
you can think that more as the
internal stuff, internal laws.
But when you think about
the energy conversion, what
does it really-- energy
conversion-- mean?
Energy conversion is one type of
energy going to the other type,
right?
So when gas molecule
drive a turbine,
it's this kinetic energy
becomes the average motion
of the blade.
Now, another type is think
about the photovoltaic cell.
What's the energy conversion?
Of course, what you want is
the photon eventually come out
and get the electricity, right?
But what you get in
the microscopic level
is an electron is
sent over here.
A photon comes in and
lift the electron to here.
You have the first step of
your energy conversion already.
Of course, that's not a
photovoltaic cell, yet,
and the light from the lamp
is absorbed by all the stuff
around us, eventually.
That's energy conversion,
except at the end,
we can't capture it.
And so you have different
losses in the process
that you have to take care if
you want to finally extract
things that's useful.
OK, so this kind of interaction
is dealing with the collision,
dealing with the interaction.
This is arguably the
most complicated step
in the transport.
Now, with that,
let's go to what I
want to give you is a simple
kinetic theory of transport.
So I know their, say, how
long air molecule travel,
and I know their velocity.
What I'm going to
do next is to show
how we can do a simple
derivation for the Fourier
law of heat conduction.
And I said that you can do
the same derivation using
the same strategy
for mass diffusion,
for momentum transfer.
And in fact, you have
homework on this.
So I'm considering conduction
only now averaging motion,
right?
I have the gas
molecules and any gas.
In fact, it applies to the
electron, applies to photon,
as long as I have
this gas picture.
And I have a temperature
gradient in the x-direction.
So this is a p flow
in the x-direction--
temperature gradient there.
And I want to derive
the Fourier law.
And microscopically,
if I can count--
basically, I'm counting.
So when I look at the flux
across certain cross section--
so here, I'm going to say
this is the cross section I'm
looking at.
Here is x.
On the left, I have molecules.
On the right, I have molecules.
And the molecules are
doing random motion.
And on the left, they are
slight higher temperature.
On the right, slightly
lower temperature.
Now, some of these
molecule will go
across this imaginary interface
I draw without collision.
So I count that--
those molecule that can
go through the interface.
So from left to right,
mass from right to
left-- that's my left flux.
So I'm doing my energy balance.
And so what I
count, I say, left I
have here within how high--
say, what's the range?
This is the vx times tau.
Tau is the time
between collision.
That's something I
forgot to mention--
tau.
Because I have a
mean free path, so I
have the mean free path divide
by velocity that gives me--
or speed-- gives me the
average time between collision.
So I say, vx--
because this is velocity
in the x-component,
in x-direction-- we
have x times tau.
As long as those molecules
is within this range,
they can go across this
imaginary interface here.
And of course, only half
of them have that chance.
Half goes this way.
Half goes the other way.
I'm doing the random--
random Brownian motion.
So I have my q is 1/2.
This is the average number
per unit per unit volume.
And times vx--
this is the speed.
So if you look at
this, this gives
me here is per unit volume.
Here is meter per second.
So that gives me per
meter squared per second.
That's how they flux--
the flux of the particles
per meter squared per second.
And times each particle
carry this energy.
So you can replace
that energy by charge.
That's a diffusion of charge.
If you do 1, that's
a diffusion--
or if you times the
mass of a particle,
that's a diffusion of mass
in terms of the weight.
So here is x mass vx times tau.
That's on the left
going into right.
And the mass from the
right going to left--
so there also half of this--
this is also vx over tau.
That's the chance going
from left to the right.
So that's the difference
of the two gives me--
you say here that
it's vx plus tau.
So that's my heat flux.
If you check, this is a
1 over meter squared--
cubic.
Here is meter per second.
Here is joule.
So I will get a Watt
per meter squared.
And of course, what
I'm going to do next--
oh, here is vx--
x components.
What I'm going to do
next is to write that
into differentiable form.
This is very short.
As long as I'm dealing
with microscopic,
I can write this 100-nanometer
range into differentiable form.
So I do my differential.
What I have is q equals--
because this is a
positive, it's minus.
So I have minus in the front--
1/2 d nvx tau--
E. That's what's inside.
And dx.
And the x difference
is vx tau mass vx tau.
So I have 2 vx tau.
So now I'm doing a
little [INAUDIBLE]..
I'm going to put the vx--
pull vx out.
I neglect all those temperature
dependence of velocity.
And this is actually because
you can have a [INAUDIBLE]
the mass heat transfer.
But I'm escaping-- making
the science easier.
So what I have here
is one 1/2 cancel.
I have vx squared tau and d
n times E is U and the dx.
U is energy per unit volume.
So vx squared is
1/3 of v squared.
I'm doing-- right?
So what I have here--
oh, the negative sign.
So I have 1/3 v
squared tau and dU dT--
I'm using chain rule--
dT, dX.
What's dU, dT?
That's the heat-- yeah,
specific heat per unit volume.
So this one is--
c is the specific heat is
joule meter cubic Kelvin.
Typically, we do specific
per unit density--
per unit mass.
But it's fine.
So what I have here is
k, Fourier law, dT, dX.
And I also obtain expression for
k is 1/3 cv tau squared, right?
No, cv squared tau.
cv squared tau, which
is 1/3 c gamma v--
cv gamma.
So this is the
Fourier law and also
the expression for
thermal conductivity.
OK.
And if you look at
thermal connectivity,
it's proportional to
the mean free path,
proportional velocity,
proportional specific heat.
If you check for gas--
which gas has the highest
thermal conductivity?
AUDIENCE: Helium
PROFESSOR: Helium.
So the velocity is higher.
OK.
And so we have-- with that,
I have the simple derivation.
And later on, we're
going to give you
more complicated derivation
based on Boltzmann equation.
But this is a [INAUDIBLE]
one, and it's pretty good.
At the end, if you
use the Boltzmann,
you'll still get k
equals 1/3 of cv gamma.
OK, any questions
here, or doubt?
If not, let's make
a few comment.
So those, of course,
are what we learned--
the classical defusing
theory, right?
And you can say
immediately, if I
do take the example
of the disk drive,
my space is much smaller
than this mean free path.
I cannot do the
derivative anymore.
So I have to go to look
at more complicated--
so this is where the
nano start to deviate.
So what we're looking at when
we're looking into the, what's
the fundamental difference?
So I have-- and what's, really,
the micro/nano fundamental
difference?
And there are several regimes.
One is I always have a
device characteristic length.
For example, in the
slider, the disk drive
is the separation
between slider and disk.
So I have one is a
characteristic length.
The mean free path--
if the mean free
path becomes larger
or comparable to
separation-- let's say,
d, a characteristic length
of the transport problem.
And in that case, the diffusion
theory will no longer be valid,
and the air molecule will
collide with the boundary.
And as long as the quantum
effects are not important,
then you run into a
classical size effect regime.
So classical size effect.
So this is one case.
But you can ask, how do you know
your quantum size effect is not
important?
So let's take a look.
Now, we're going to move
a little bit into quantum.
So the next case is a
quantum size effect.
And in fact, sometimes I don't
like to call it a quantum size
effect.
I like to call it wave effect.
And this is a case
when you have to think
about the wavelength as another
characteristic than scale.
And I prefer to call
this save effects.
I'm sure that people don't
always agree with me.
But say, here,
let's take a look.
Plus, with the quantum--
with the wave-- take
a basic picture here.
We know we're going to get into
more in the next lecture that--
see, anything from
quantum picture
is both a wave and
the particle, right?
So wave has a wavelength.
So we have a wavelength.
This is my lambda.
And in the quantum
picture, again,
say we're going
more in the lecture.
The wavelength and the
momentum is related
through the Planck constant, h.
h is a Planck constant--
6.6 10 to the minus
34 joule second.
So now, when the wave's
effect important,
I'm going to give a very
simple argument-- example.
In fact, you will say that
a significant difference--
even though we, in
most of my research
is fall into classical
size effect regime,
but I've been
always thinking it's
much better if you start
with the wave picture
to understand how the wave
goes from wave to the particle.
Why?
That's because when you go nano,
there is always the interface.
Interface-- ideal interface--
is zero thickness.
Zero thickness compare anything
is too thin, too small, right?
So there, the wave
effect always--
one can start with
think about the way
reflection at the interface.
So even though most
of you probably
don't deal with
waves very often,
I want to emphasize the
wave-- spend a lot of time
talking about the waves.
So let me make a simple
argument of standing wave.
I have a film.
Or in the first lecture, I
say, if you go to Professor
[INAUDIBLE] website, you'll
see he makes beautiful dots--
nano-sized dots.
And so I simplify that.
As a film, I make a
two-dimensional, very thin,
freestanding film.
I got the electron wave inside.
I have a charger
inside, or I have atom.
You can think of either way.
So this is a wave inside.
And then there is a boundary
you cannot come out.
So what do you have there?
So confine the boundary--
simplest picture is clamped.
You say, OK, my wave--
I thought that depends--
I wasn't sure I'm
coming to this stage,
so I didn't bring
the violin I have.
AUDIENCE: It's a standing wave.
PROFESSOR: It's a standing wave.
So let's start with
standing wave picture.
And I have a final thickness.
Let me say my simplest
picture is standing wave
with at the boundary
is zero vibration.
I clamp these two boundaries.
So then my waveform--
this is a standing wave--
the simplest one mode
of standing wave.
And the next mode--
right?
So I have those different
modes of standing wave inside.
And I can use the
expression I gave
and this requirement to give
you basic quantization result.
So how we do it?
Lambda over 2-- that's
the basic length.
And here is 2 times lambda
over 2, so it's just lambda.
And times n.
This n is an integer--
no longer the number
density anymore.
So lambda over 2 times n should
equal to the thickness, d,
or diameter automatically.
So this is d.
And this gives me
lambda equals 2d over n.
And that will give me
momentum equal h over lambda.
And that's 2ndh--
wait, wait, wait.
Sorry.
So 2nh over-- no.
nh over 2d.
That's momentum.
OK, now I say I come
to kinetic energy.
This is a--
I'm jumping, here.
I say, OK, this wave
also has a momentum
and has a kinetic energy.
And this is quantized momentum
because that n must be integer.
n equals 1, 2--
right?
So now the energy, En, is--
if I do the classical,
it's mv squared.
And I write that into
momentum squared--
2m-- because the momentum is mv.
I put the momentum in.
So I will get 8md squared and
n squared times h squared.
So now, suddenly, the
energy of this particle
discontinues because of
the wave requirement.
So I need to ask,
is this important?
So that clearly depends on,
what's the m, and what's the n?
If the m and--
say, what's the m
and what's the d?
If m and d are large, the
energy separation is very small.
If they are small, this
becomes very important.
How important it is?
So we need to have,
again, order of magnitude,
even though I always give
you very small numbers,
but I want you to be
proficient in those numbers.
You can choose
whatever unit you use.
So let me first give order
of magnitude of kBT, right?
We said everything is equal
partition and 1/2 kBT.
So kBT is good
number to remember.
How large is kBT?
kBT is a 1.38 10 to the minus
23rd joule Kelvin and times 300
Kelvin.
And this gives me--
let me do that by heart.
OK, it's 4.16 10 to
the minus 21 joule.
You see, I don't
remember this number.
The problem-- the reason
is, here I make a jump.
Most of the time, I like to
remember in electron volts.
One electron volt
is one electron--
actually, under one
volt, what's the energy?
So one electron-- what's
the charge of electron--
in the 19 coulomb times of
1 volt. So this is 1.6 10
to the minus 19 joule.
And if you convert
this kBT into joule,
this is 26 milli electron
volt. That's what I remember.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, I used to be able
to do brain calculations.
26 milli electron volts.
That's room temperature.
OK, so why I do that?
Let's go look at the En.
I'm going to put the
electron into a film.
Let's say the film
is 100 angstrom--
10 nanometer.
OK, so why an electron--
oh, let's be consistent--
electron in 10 nanometer film.
What's a mass of the electron?
9.1 10 to the minus 31 kilogram.
OK, so you plug in the number.
Here is 9.1 10 to the
minus 31 kilograms.
Here is 10 minus--
because the 10 nanometer is 10
to the minus 8 meter squared.
h is 6.6 10 to the
minus 34 joule second.
So you do that.
I have number here.
I have then En for electron
is 0.6 10 to the minus 21 n
squared in terms of joule.
Or in terms of
electron volt, it's
0.37 10 to the minus 2
m squared electron volt.
So I said kBT is 26
milli electron volts.
So if you look at the electron
in this 10-nanometer film,
the separation between
energy n equals 1,
equals 2, that's a-- difference
is 3 times those number.
That becomes comparable
to kBT, right?
So this shows the quantum
effect become important.
But if it's an air molecule
in this space, the m,
now, goes 20--
so remember, the proton
mass is 2,000 times larger.
So this energy separation
becomes very small
if it's an air molecule.
So for air molecule,
I don't need
to worry about
quantum size effect.
But for electron, I
need to [INAUDIBLE]..
So this is where--
when we go to nano--
we could encounter both quantum
and classical size effect.
And also, as I said,
either the interface--
if it's an ideal interface--
thickness is zero--
the way picture always
becomes very, very important.
And final comment-- so we
have quantum size effect,
classical size effect.
The final comment is a time.
I shoot a laser, a very fast
laser-- microsecond laser--
you see, can use Fourier
law to describe transport.
And when does that
become important?
This is where-- this tau,
the time becomes important.
And you need to look at
your transport process.
How does that
compare to this time?
So mean free path
for air molecule--
100 nanometer, velocity--
500.
So that's about 10 to
the minus 8 second.
So if you do microsecond,
don't worry about it.
If you do picosecond
or nanosecond,
you start to worry about it.
So you have time scale.
You have length scale.
And this is where you
need to be able to tell--
you're safe in one
regime, you need
to go, say, you have to think
about what kind of size effect,
or what kind of effects?
Any questions?
OK.
If not, remember, I
would like to see you
in my office hour, and
preferably preferably,
the first few weeks.